sieht aus wie in der karibik in kroatien
oder auf den schwedischen scheren inseln
aber wir sind am eibsee am fuß der
zugspitze und auf ihrem gipfel der
höchste berg der deutschen der auch eine
österreichische seite hat und eine
schlucht die einfach nur atemberaubend
schön ist die höllentalbahn durch die
ein wanderweg von grainau richtung
gipfel führt ein wunder der natur mit
allem was wildes wasser zu bieten hat es
tust und gurgelt es rauscht und dröhnt
so dass man kaum sein eigenes wort
versteht
viele wege führen auf die zugspitze dass
sie als einer der spektakulärsten durch
die hellen tag lang den gehen wir heute
und wie überall gilt hier
wir sind zwar draußen aber auf den wegen
und in den tunnels der klamm kann es
sehr eng werden hunderte besucher nehmen
diesen weg jeden tag aber nicht alle
gehen weiter bis zum gipfel denn das ist
nur was für echte bergsteiger
die anderthalb stunden durch die klamm
schafft man auch als normal
es wird halt ein bisschen nass und
rutschig zwischendrin ich finde es total
schön mit der natur und jetzt wo die
sonne nicht mehr scheint ist richtig
schön das wasser spiegelt sich und sie
treten natürlich aus
es ist sehr erstaunlich wasser wasser
alles anstellen kann schauen was
irgendwie von reagieren dass du eine
kindergruppe in der tat in jahrmillionen
hat das wasser sich hier durch die
felsen gefräst bis diese klamm
entstanden ist mit ihren 70 meter hohen
wänden
auch einheimische werden nicht müde
diesen weg zu gehen
brauchst doch mal beim drinnen oder mal
andere sterne oder sie schon mal
irgendwo sturz oder was das ist immer
ein bisschen anders und immer wieder
steht nur das wasser kommt von allen
seiten und es ist sehr schattig das
heißt auch beim schönsten sommerwetter
ist es gut eine regenjacke dabei zu
haben aber es lohnt sich
war schon ein bisschen klang in anklam
im programm vertraut sind
plötzlich ist wieder sommer mit 20 grad
auf gut 1000 metern höhe von hier aus
ist es nicht mehr weit bis zum
einkehrschwung auf der höllental einer
hütte rast und nachtlager für ernsthaft
der zugspitz bergsteiger lang ersehnter
traum wir würden gerne nämlich hätten
jubiläumsgrat machen hier übermorgen
wenn das wetter mitmacht ja einmal
höchster berg von deutschland da treffen
welten aufeinander
oben am gipfel die einen sind gebrochen
hatten angst sich dazu bewegen die
anderen die anderen kommen
denn jubiläumsgrat bzw würden gletscher
also unter treffen flip flops auf
wanderschuhe und ihr seid die mit den
wanderschuhen zwischen der hütte und dem
gipfel liegen der höllental gletscher
oder eine anspruchsvolle kraxelei
deshalb sollte ab hier nur weitergehen
wer steigeisen helm und klettergurt
dabei hat haben wir nicht aber die
flipflops die kann man an der zugspitze
tatsächlich auch gebrauchen allerdings
nur unten am see
da gibt es echtes strand feeling für
alle wasserratten unter den berg
wechseln
so kann man hier laien und schnell raus
paddeln in liedberg inselwelt gerne auch
mit schwimmweste
oder mit dem tretboot super tolles
panorama demmel ist ganz klar auch der
see das wasser man kann bis auf den
grund sehen es wirklich sehr schön ist
sehr vielseitig und man muss nicht weit
fahren in deutschland um noch solchen
bild zu bekommen
auf dem see herrscht göttliche ruhe
wirklich sehr erholsam und auch
schwimmen lässt es sich hier noch gut
übrigens auch auf der anderen seite der
zugspitze in österreich oberhalb von
ehrwald gibt es einen see der es an
schönheit mit dem aufnehmen kann und ein
bisschen abgelegener ist der 7 c auf
1660 metern höhe
die meisten trauen sich nur mit den
füßen rein
aber alpin schwimmer hansjörg ransmayr
reicht das nicht
obwohl der see nur zehn grad hat will er
ins wasser
und zwar richtig seit 20 jahren schwimmt
der 61 jährige österreicher durch alles
was kein pool ist
je einsamer und wilder das gewässer
desto besser das geheimnis ist man
schwimmt in die kalte jahreszeit hinein
im herbst wenn es kälter wird immer
weiter schwimmen dann kann sich der
körper gut anpassen dann ist es kein
wirklich beeindruckend selbst für diesen
ehrwalder der den see schon immer kennt
zum erfrischen ist eine kurze ein kurzer
trip natürlich fein aber wenn man
gesundheitlich positive effekte haben
will muss man schon das zittern auch in
kauf nehmen nach ja so gut dann probiere
ich es auch mal die trockenen sachen
kommen in einer art boje an der man sich
zur not festhalten kann ist aber wichtig
als kälteschutz und theoretisch könnte
man sogar auf der anderen seite weiter
wandern aber dazu kommt es nicht
ich drehe lieber wieder um
die kälte ordentlichkeit aber es stimmt
man fühlt sich wie neu geboren
genug vom wasser jetzt ist endlich der
gipfel dran
wer es in die gondel geschafft hat hat
schon geduld bewiesen beim schlange
stehen dafür geht es dann in fünf
minuten zum gipfelplateau auf knapp 3000
metern
dort ist schon am vormittag die hölle
los
tausende besucher drängen sich auf den
aussichtsterrassen und genießen den
ausblick
zwischen all dem stahl und beton steht
noch eine museumsreife hütte das
münchner haus des deutschen alpenvereins
die höchst gelegene hütte deutschland
auf dem höchsten berg des landes 18 97
gebaut worden ist mir die haare jede
einzelne schindel jedes bretter
auftragen sind anders über sein tun mit
dem uniqa aufgetragen und dabei große
satteldach geht nicht darum werden da
bis zu 220 mio die windgeschwindigkeit
der reißt die hütte weg du siehst du
diese ab spannung dieses start-up
spannung in die begegnung gehen
die hatten wirklich gemacht damit die
hütte nicht darauf legt dass die
behörden stehen bleibt über das rheintal
sind auch die erstbesteiger der
zugspitze gegangen vor 200 jahren
es ist der einfachste aber auch der
längste weg zum gipfel steiler und
anspruchsvoller ist der weg über die
höllental einer hütte denn diese beiden
bergsteiger genommen haben
ist es wichtig den höchsten gipfel
deutschlands mal bestiegen zu haben für
dich wichtig nicht sicher wie viel wir
haben es noch den weg wie hoch er
gesprochen
natürlich ist es schön nochmal auf das
gipfelkreuz drauf zu schauen aber er
wird ihr hoch hat sich schon gelohnt ein
bisschen ernüchternd für die echten
bergsteiger auch sie müssen anstehen für
den gipfel
genau wie die bergfahrer die mit der
gondel hergekommen sind
es kann schon mal eine halbe stunde
dauern bis man dann tatsächlich am
gipfelkreuz steht das ulkige ist dass es
ja gar nicht der ursprüngliche gibt da
aber es gibt viel kreuz steht das ist
nicht die ursprünglich von der zugspitze
gestartet ein stückchen weiter gegen das
sogenannte west gipfel und den hat 1938
kam den die nazis weggesprengt weil es
in europa flakstellung aufbauen wollten
die flak stellung wurde nie gebaut aber
die zugspitze ist seitdem einige meter
niedriger nämlich nur noch 2962 meter
warum hat es geglaubt man kommt dann
darauf was sie so spitze dieser
mystische berg da waren die götter zu
hause durfte man nicht erzwingen und wie
man sich es war mal früher jemand oben
vor die 200 jahre aber die
erstbesteigung ist jetzt dieses jahr
eben auf 200 jahre datiert
die sicht reicht an schönen tagen bis
zum großglockner und in die
französischen alpen für den höchsten
berg deutschlands auf dem gipfel für
sich haben möchte muss wirklich früh
aufstehen denn bevor die erste gondel
kommt sind hier nur ganz wenige menschen
das lohnt sich auch 200 jahre nach der
erstbesteigung